I don't know Pete Davidson at all I  don't even know if I've been around him  and I feel like I would remember because  he's a very Dynamic person  I'm making a wild guess here he seems  like someone who really knows how to let  himself fall in love a hundred percent  cosign on that idea yes he I think he I  think he like likes it like I think he  really and I and I admire that me too I  I'm kind of like that too where I'm like  let's go for it like I I live to fall in  love I don't even mind about the  Heartbreak it's fine I'll take the good  with the bad and he goes for it I know  and by the way every woman that has been  with him Kate Beckinsale Kim Kardashian  they all talk about how wonderful he is  I know there's not a bad word about him  on the street and I know a few people  who have worked with him and they're  like no he is the greatest